what's going on reject nation Gregor
here John here so Greg and John today we
have a patreon the real rejects become a
page one injected a join us one of the
rewards here's their is that whatever
you request whether it be a reaction or
a discussion most people request
reactions Rosa Park West at a discussion
on something that we're gonna shoot this
week and but anyway Nathan Wilton in
today's your video the big let's show
season 2 episode 5 busted we saw the
first video of this it was weird
really strange I don't know if it's a
continuing story line or not I just
don't get too close to the lips or Holy
Mother
don't worry might get more drugs and
praise your [ __ ] project [ __ ]
though your breath you feathers you know
where's your fat green friend
thank you again mr. Sasquatch you were
carrying every drug under the planet in
the back of your vehicle under the
employer you know [ __ ] weekend when we
go that I you're [ __ ] going straight
to prison
sassy oh I can't [ __ ] believe don't
go to why you needed to help Liz Ruby
space you'd be cheated into it back I'm
gonna look at these [ __ ] filthy
convicts strutting around on behind a
place
[Music]
Oh is he in there hey cuz that [ __ ]
place sassy man man do I wish I wish I
was hi I'm watching this video I could
see how that would be beneficial I could
see how that would have made it is for
this one I know what's weird is the last
one made me laugh too that we watch by
ourselves invisible after a bit more the
first one yeah I don't know why it's so
funny - this is so weird and strange I
like cartoons when they're weird and
strange but then their dialogue is just
normal yeah I don't know why but
something very amusing about animation
projects like this where you could tell
it's just like something a dude made to
just try and get better at him and like
the weirdness because the first one we
watched was really surreal this one is
to just do a much lesser degree that
stuff can be really entrancing well it
feels like these people or whoever made
this you know thought it was funny in
his mind like I can see him like typing
it out funny if we made this a gorilla
it's so strange no particular strong
storyline I love it yeah weird ass way I
really love weirdly I think I might want
to keep up with this in some kind of
marginal way these guys from Australia
they must be I mean Nathan Wilson
Australia you know we did a Google
hangout with Nathan Wilson and this dude
is a very attractive Aussie man sexy we
know - Aussie people part of our patreon
and I want them to fight and see who can
make the other one ugly is right now
both of them are very good-looking
people
Nathan Wilson young he likes money
actually after getting to know him
and I could just see him cracking up
hysterically at this thing oh yeah III
imagined him in my mind while we were
watching this like it was actually those
walks and Nathan in front of you you
know reactive or like an oculus oculus
thing that you're using that to us it's
a little challenging to make like
something really great review commentary
but I enjoy it I do enjoy it well it
seems like as compared to the first
episode this is part of something much
more broad now I get the sense that this
series has grown beyond the simple kinds
of lessons sassy trying drugs together
this videos from 2013 yeah they just
uploaded another episode episode 4
episode 2 season 4 so 2 or dang
animation was grown - oh yeah I can tell
just by the thumbnail that the animation
is grown whoa that's great I wish I
could make something I wonder if it's
like faster paced now or something this
is definitely like a real show now looks
like they've evolved they've grown
well guys check out the Big West show if
you can les is a person I thought it's
gonna be lesbians it was as a person
he's just a big guy le Z well subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell and hey do yourself a
favor and follow - on Humphrey on
Twitter oh yeah dude please if you like
to become a patreon just add a little
bit did the but today is decent rubies